all right from criminal minds to the
young and the restless and now swat
shamar moore continues his 20-year plus
acting career and jillian caught up with
him in advance of this weekend's 100th
episode up swat check it out how's my
team good now buddy send in the bomb
squad move in let's talk about swat
we're about to see the 100th episode
what do you think has made this show so
successful to get to this point because
this is a huge milestone yeah no i'm
really proud of it you know to hit 100 i
mean it's i pinch myself i mean i
pitched myself just in i've been in this
game 28 years and it's hard enough to
get in this game what's great about swat
is it's an everybody show um
because who doesn't like super cool cops
doing super cool things and chasing down
bad guys and so i get to play and we go
we all get to play somewhat of
superheroes it's like when we were kids
playing cops and robbers and now we're
adults getting paid to go out there and
fly running helicopters and motorcycle
chases and car chases and hand-to-hand
combat
you know so that's the fun part of swat
and it's fun to be the leader of a team
you're putting a lot on the line riding
with me today
i appreciate it this role is intense for
you i think i remember in the beginning
you actually were injured right off the
bat have you
found a way to you know make sure you're
staying safe but still getting in
character as much as possible
i have i have scrapes on my shin i'm not
going to show you but i have scrapes on
my shin right now from a stunt we just
did a few days ago where i had the mic
because what what happened when i had
the
parkour they say
i'm not a parkour guy i'm just athletic
enough that i can jump off of
i can jump off a stump up onto a railing
and then pull myself up and you know
they didn't want me to do it but my stun
my stunt team knows that i'm athletic
enough that i can do certain things so
what i do in a given day is i let we all
have stunt dogs so a lot of people say
do you do your own stunts i i'm proud to
say i do as much as they'll let me do
and i want to do all of it so i would
say i do about 80 of my own stuff
there's certain things that the studio
network won't let you do because you
could break limbs you could die
you know so if you see hondo jumping
across across a roof
uh from really high up that's probably
not me but you'll see me running to do
it cut and then they'll let my crazy
stunt double go do it but what happens
is he'll do the whole sequence
i'll memorize the choreography in the
sequence i'll watch him do it and then
i'll do my version of it so that the
editing they can cut from him to me and
they'll use as much as me as long as it
looks cool but
he can make me look even cooler you're
taking on this role you're a producer
sonic the hedgehog i mean how do you
have time for everything
i'm not i'm not the star of sonic the
hedgehog we'll leave that up to jim
carrey and james marsden and
natasha rothwell and tikka sumter it was
just like outside the box for me it was
like i'm so used to you know being
dramatic and chasing bad guys and being
a tough guy and now i got to be this
charming silly
fun guy in this crazy world of a cartoon
character i mean a lot of looking at
tennis balls talking to tennis balls and
you know talking to pieces of tape
things that weren't there because it was
all going to be animated
so it was just very different well
shemar you do it all congratulations on
everything 100 episodes of swat we can't
wait to watch it thank you so much for
for taking the time and i hope you enjoy
the rest of your day all right take care
of yourself oh he said darling not baby
girl oh come on
all right swat airs sunday at 10 pm
right here on cbs and is available live
and on streaming for streaming on
paramount plus don't miss the 100th
episode of swat this sunday april 10th
he is a vet in the game he's been